year retirement age
their retirement age
that was unnecessary but really no it
was necessary yeah I thought I deserve
it see what's happening to you guys
you're New Yorkers so you're bitching
and moaning about nothing
[Laughter]
that is so true we're in Florida now you
don't have to complain about every
little thing
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that's right people
you're in Florida now well I'm in
Florida and you're watching me in
Florida and you might be in Florida and
if you're not in Florida you probably
wish you were in Florida I'm Dave Rubin
this is the Reuben report it's November
21st 2022. uh that was Friday's Greg
Gutfeld with an exclavation Point
program the number one show in late
night TV uh I did that over at the Hard
Rock Hotel in Hollywood Florida which is
becoming the new Hollywood actually uh
that was during the Fox Nation Patriot
Awards I was there for a couple days all
The Usual Suspects Gutfeld and Tucker
and Brian Kilmeade and the morning guys
and everybody was there and it was a
celebration actually not of the on-air
talent but of some of the good decent
people who do good work whether it's in
donations service military members
families who've lost loved ones for this
country it was a celebration of of those
folks it was really quite wonderful and
then of course the few days before that
I was in the swamp in D.C and we sat
down with Rand Paul and Jim Jordan and
Byron Donalds and a couple other people
I'm heading back to DC in a week or so
to do a little something with the
Congressional Republicans and it does
seem like uh things are happening people
so I wanted to do the show I was talking
to Phoenix over the weekend I wanted to
do a show a little bit differently this
week and maybe a little bit
differently say to the end of the year
as the holidays roll in and everything
else because you know we uh when
elections come you get lost in the
racehorse politics part of all of this
stuff and the polls say this and this
person says that and we better get the
Arizona Governor's seat and blah blah
blah and all of those things but of
course what leads us to all of those
fights are the culture wars right the
culture wars that have just been brewing
all of the stuff related to gender and
sexuality and racism and how Hollywood
California has imploded and politics we
say this all the time it's a line from
Andrew ripe our politics is Downstream
from culture so when you wonder why
maybe there wasn't the Red Wave although
the Republicans did get the house and
Nancy Pelosi has been booted and they're
already starting to investigate things
with Hunter Biden and Joe Biden and a
whole bunch more uh but when you wonder
why they why there wasn't the red wave
that if you watch this show or if you're
roughly a sane person you know how was
there not a red wave people have had it
with all this stuff we know the economy
is in bad shape the Ukraine war is all
Bizarro weird and all of the stuff it's
like well we have to accept that the
culture has brainwashed a tremendous
amount of people and what do we do with
that so regardless of how good our ideas
might be and how much better our
candidates might be than somebody like
say John fetterman uh x amount of people
a huge swath of Americans are going to
vote for the bad ideas not only vote for
the bad ideas they're going to vote for
people that would gladly take from some
and give to others and then create
government programs they never go
anywhere and keep people in cycles of
poverty and all of those things so what
I wanted to do maybe
for the rest of the year it's not that
I'm going to get away from politics
there's obviously politics involved in
what we're going to do today and always
but get back a little bit to the to the
issues in the culture War because
otherwise we'll just do day-to-day
politics forever and I don't know if you
heard about this but Donald Trump is
running for president and uh that's
going to keep you know half the world
sort of focused on that more than
anything else so really we either have
to get rid of our old institutions or we
have to rebuild them but they have been
plagued and infected by leftism at sort
of every level that's what we're going
to be going through today and let's
start actually with sort of the big
thing at the moment it's not just that
Donald Trump has announced that he is
running for president and a lot of
people are excited a lot of people were
freaking out all The Usual Suspects
chiming in on it but now even scarier
than having Donald Trump return as
president potentially he has returned on
the Twitter that's right Elon Musk on
Friday put up a poll now these polls
last for 24 hours once you put it up so
you can see he put it up on the 18th
over 15 million people voted on this
which is a lot of people that is a lot
of people to click a button and you can
see the results about 52 percent to 48
said yes
reinstate Donald Trump so at the end of
the poll Elon Musk I mean he's got a way
of running things he wrote the people
have spoken Trump will be reinstated and
you can see an image here of Donald
Trump's Twitter account which is now
back up now first off let me just
address one thing related to the poll
itself
is having a poll the best way of
deciding who should be banned and who
shouldn't be banned of course not
because you wouldn't want a majority
deciding that dissident voices minority
voices shouldn't be allowed on a
platform so I'm sure Elon Musk is well
aware of that he did this it was a
little bit of a troll move it was a
little bit of a a fun silly Thing by him
but there is of course a danger in
leaving these things up purely to pulse
is the truth that had the poll gone the
other way that Trump wouldn't be back on
and that would be the policy of Twitter
I mean that wouldn't make much sense
right so he has also said by the way
Elon Musk has also said that Alex Jones
will not be allowed back on Twitter he
has not left that one up to a poll so I
don't think all his decision making uh I
don't think all the decision making that
he'll be doing will be based on polls
but it but it is a little bit of a
dangerous game to do that of course
right just because you get more votes in
something doesn't mean you're morally
right or just or good or anything else
anyway interestingly Viva Frey who of
course is a friend of the Reuben report
a friend of mine and he's a lawyer and
he is a former Canadian now living down
here living the good life here in the
Free State of Florida he went in and did
a little digging on what it was that
Donald Trump was banned for in the first
place so he posted a couple of
screenshots from the original Twitter
statement so there you can see a bunch
of them I'm just going to read you some
of the highlights some of those yellow
highlights those are his highlights that
he put in those screenshots there uh and
uh sorry Phoenix can you just go back up
please going the wrong way there on the
prompter there we go he wrote holy
Shiite I've never realized how ludicrous
the justification to ban Donald Trump
was this does not read like a
justification it reads like a deranged
fabrication Elon Musk was right to fire
anyone and everyone who had a hand in
this idiocy and then he goes in here a
couple of the quotes specifically how
they are being received and interpreted
on and off Twitter of course he's
talking about Trump's tweets is being
received by a number of his supporters
as further confirmation that the
election was not legitimate and is seen
as him disavowing his previous claim may
also serve as encouragement to those
potentially considering violent acts at
that the inauguration American Patriots
is also being interpreted as support for
those committing violent acts at the U.S
Capitol giant voice is being interpreted
as further indication that President
Trump does not plan to facilitate
orderly transition the two tweets above
are likely to inspire others to
replicate the violent attacks that took
place on January 6 2021. so the way I
read that I think might have been a
little confusing but obviously what he
was doing there he was highlighting
certain quotes in Twitter's statement
regarding Trump tweets leading up to
January 6 and you can see they're all
basically sort of conjecture there's
nothing in there like Donald Trump
directly called for violence at the
Capitol Donald Trump demanded that his
supporters commit some sort of
insurrection Donald Trump is using this
platform to promote illegal activity
there was nothing like there was sort of
these amorphous ideas around some of
this stuff he may not leave the
presidency people might interpret what
he says as this or that
etc etc so it's it's pretty interesting
but as Donald Trump has come back on
Twitter and as Elon Musk has taken over
Elon as you know has also fired a slew
of people I think over a thousand people
and the product still seems to be
working right he's he's firing people
left and right and everything seems to
be working I think you could make a
fairly strong argument that things are
working actually better than before
because it seems like a shadow banning's
going away they're allowing a whole
bunch of other accounts to come back and
it does seem like traction is starting
to make more sense all of those things
and once again I won't always say it I
promise you every time we talk about
Twitter
I know this always feels a little myopic
when you talk about Twitter but it is
the Public Square in the digital space
at least at the moment so if you're not
on there God bless you you're probably
doing something right and you're
probably happier and more efficient in
using your time but it is the place that
the stuff starts right that that culture
War
that I started talking about that's
where the fight is happening and then
that leaks out into real life so you may
not care about Twitter but what happens
on Twitter cares about you so anyway as
he has fired all of these people at
Twitter uh a lot of lefties are freaking
out and saying they're going to leave
Twitter they're gonna go build things
and blah blah blah they're not going to
build anything because Equity doesn't
lead you to being able to build anything
you're too focused on your engineer's
skin color one of the people that's not
happy about Elon Musk is a-o-c he she
wrote on Twitter shout out to all the
workers at Twitter you all built a vital
place for connected and deserved so much
for connection and deserve so much
better millions of people appreciate the
space you built and the hard work that
went into it thank you uh and then Elon
Musk I mean he's getting good at this
you're welcome that's all he wrote
you're welcome now just quickly on the
AOC thing and these people that are
upset by what's happening on Twitter
let's understand this clearly you Elon
Musk has not come in and said I'm going
to censor people on the left he has not
said I'm going to trample on anyone's
free speech he has said we are going to
allow more voices here he has said we
are going to try to respect Free Speech
a little more honestly and we're gonna
we're gonna be a little more upfront
about our policies we're not going to
randomly or not even randomly because we
don't know if it's random or not we are
not going to use the levers of power as
our employees see fit to decide who the
winners or losers are who you can see
and who you can't see and everything
else now who's that upsetting to isn't
this so interesting that's upsetting to
all the lefties because they're
realizing all the powers that be
all the blue check journalists you know
you'd see all these people from Daily
Beast or huffpo or whatever it might be
BuzzFeed that would have the blue check
and you'd go oh somebody wrote an
article and they have a blue check they
must be somewhat legitimate but now we
know they were buying the blue check or
they were getting it through their
organization now regular people can get
the blue check so it is democratizing uh
the value of your account right uh you
don't get unearned credit just because
you happen to work a Daily Beast or
something which is a crap Factory so who
is upset that there are more voices no
there it's we have no evidence right now
that suddenly there's way more threats
on Twitter and there's way more hate on
Twitter go six months ago eight months
ago four years ago I've gotten a
tremendous amount of hate on Twitter
you're not going to believe this you can
either sit there and read it or you can
press block or mute or you cannot even
open your app it's quite extraordinary
what you as a human being can do in
relationship to your little magical
device Jordan Peterson's back that's
right Elon Musk unbanned him too I mean
just perfect absolutely perfect and then
what started happening because Trump is
back
and Jordan Peterson is back and by the
way James Lindsay who's been on the
Ruben report many times he is back as of
this morning as well many people are on
their way back so what's happening well
CBS news they started freaking out and
they said they were going to leave
Twitter
in light of the uncertainty around
Twitter and out of an abundance of
caution CBS News is pausing its activity
on the social media site as it continues
to monitor the platform major Johnson
Vigliotti thank you the uncertainty and
out of an abundance of caution the
uncertainty the uncertainty of free
speech the uncertainty that people will
be able to communicate with each other
without the lever uh being pushed so
that someone is seen more and someone is
seen less
and that is scary to CBS News well when
that clip started making its way around
the Twitter all sorts of people were
commenting on it here's what Jordan said
on that this is excellent news good work
Elon Musk the corrupt Legacy Media hate
you you can tell a good man by the
quality of his enemies and that is a
retweet of a New York Post article
regarding CBS News and then this is just
absolutely hilarious this all happened
within 48 Hours CBS News is back yeah
that's right uh here's a tweet from
variety CBS News resumes Twitter posting
after Hiatus over security concerns
let's just be very very clear here there
were no security concerns no one at CBS
thought that Elon Musk was doing
anything that was going to get anyone
into trouble or harm anyone or anything
else if you directly threaten someone
you are in trouble with the law that is
beyond Twitter if you libel or slander
someone you were in trouble with the law
that is beyond Twitter what CBS News is
upset about is that guys like me and
guys like Ben Shapiro and gals like Liz
wheeler or whoever it might be that we
are getting more views than them that
their attention
the attention that you give those people
is disappearing that CNN spent what was
the number it was like 500 million
dollars on CNN plus and it collapsed
basically at launch that we can do a
show like this with my handful of
employees and work real hard and give
you something that's a little more
sensible and a heck of a lot more honest
and they don't like that suddenly
because of the blue checks and someone
coming in and saying we're not going to
manipulate information we're not going
to manipulate views we're not looking so
good so we better get off this thing
because we have to assess whether it's
going to be okay and then 24 hours later
they're back because they know they need
the freaking thing right they need the
thing but it's not just Tech it's also
media and entertainment and you're not
going to believe this they're all on the
same side of all of this stuff uh
representative Adam kinzinger who is I
don't know that I've ever said the
phrase Rhino on this have I ever said
Rhino because they always say Rhino
Republican in name only but kinzinger
who is basically a disgraced Republican
he's stepping down I'm not even sure if
is he even in Congress anymore or his
turn no he's not even in Congress
anymore major Trump derangement syndrome
never accomplished anything so he's the
perfect type of Republican to always put
on CNN so that's what they always do he
was on with Jake Tapper and Jake of
course as a Democrat activist and they
were talking about the Elon Musk poll
that led to Trump's return internet poll
Trump of course was banned from Twitter
after the January 6 Insurrection for
violating the company's policy against
glorification of violence joining us
down to discuss January 6 house
Committee Member Republican congressman
Adam kinzinger and what do you make of
Elon Musk reinstating Donald Trump
well look I mean I get that people are
on all sides of this debate the fact
that he did it with a poll of which you
know however many person of those could
have been bought that aren't real people
voting in that uh secondarily I don't
know if you know that decision should be
made by some poll and so now this idea
that he's going to come on and be
reformed everybody knows he won't
okay first I will give credit where
credit is due as I said earlier the idea
of making policy by polls is not great
right if the majority all want to
silence a small but right minority that
that is a problem right this is why we
have federalism this is why our whole
system is set up the way it is and why
we have congressional seats and all
those things because you don't want
tyranny by the majority I don't think
that is the only thing that led Elon to
doing this right I actually think had
had the nose had the no we don't want
Trump back on uh people won I think that
he would have then posted that and said
well I'm doing it anyway like that's he
was going to win this thing or get the
result that he wanted either way uh
kinsinger has no evidence that Russian
Bots led to Trump winning of course
there's no evidence of it there is a
rumor that Elon set the poll to get all
of these people to click so that he
could uncover where Bots were coming
from but kenzinger simply doesn't know
and also it was the last line is really
the reason that I'm showing you where he
basically is like well we know Trump
isn't going to change okay I don't think
Trump is going to change actually but
that doesn't mean he should have been
banned in the first place right and who
really is in power if a tech
oligarch if five people that own tech
companies can ban the president from
being able to communicate with the
people he was still the sitting
president when it happened uh then who
is really more powerful is it the
president himself or the oligarchs who
can basically go ahead and silence him
uh but it doesn't just end with
kinzinger I mean he's just sort of a
relative and irrelevant whatever Adam
Schiff who of course the congressman
from Cali who led the Sham impeachment
this guy looks like a deer in headlights
all the time he's very very scared he's
he's like one of the chief Liars right
so if you want to talk about people that
lie all the time and they'll tell you
well Trump lies all the time right Adam
Schiff lied about impeachment lied about
very fine people on both sides all of
the stuff endlessly wasted tax dollars
and times then there was the second
impeachment Russia collusion Ukraine
this blah blah blah you got it here he
is having a meltdown because Elon is
unbanning the Trump I want to begin with
the news overnight that Donald Trump has
been reinstated by Elon Musk on Twitter
watching the January 6 committee
hearings Trump's tweets were a big part
of the story to be told what do you
think of him being back on Twitter I
think it's a terrible mistake and you're
absolutely right as we showed in the
January 6 hearings the president used
that platform to incite that attack on
the Capitol and it contradicts what Elon
Musk said that he was going to establish
a council to evaluate this and and
further contradicts uh musk and his
claim concern about bots on his own
platform to subject the decision to a
poll in a platform that could be easily
abused that way it just underscores the
the erratic leadership of Twitter now
under musk but also the security
concerns with security people fleeing
Twitter and what that means for the
protection of Americans private data
so incredible because he didn't seem to
care about Americans private Data before
Elon got involved in this thing right
did he care about Americans Free Speech
before Elon got involved and we knew
that Twitter actually kind of
coordinating with the government was
hiding the hunter Biden laptop story
which by the way the Congressional
Republicans now that they've taken over
and Kevin McCarthy's The Leader the
first thing they decided to do is look
into the hunter Biden laptop maybe
that's a little bit of abstraction and
we'd really care more about the Border
or something else but they're doing
something on that and it is obviously
connected to free speech and everything
else
Schiff who has lied I mean just lied
about absolutely everything he didn't
care about who was being censored when
it was his guys that were controlling
the whole thing now he's very very
concerned but speaking of this
anti-trump swath of U.S congressmen
whether it's kinzinger or Schiff it gave
us a good excuse just to play this
classic moment this is Eric swalwell I
believe this is three years ago on MSN
it was three years ago I think yesterday
on MSNBC this is a bit of a throwaway
but it's an oldie but a goodie the
evidence is uncontradicted that the
president used taxpayer dollars to ask
the ukrainians to help them cheat an
election and the complaint that I've
heard from
we've been sitting on that one no
punited can we play it again because you
can because there was the rumor so what
happened that was Eric swalwell farting
on MSNBC okay with with Chris Matthews
who had to step down he got canceled for
something nobody can even remember
anymore but Eric swallow who by the way
slept with a Chinese spy everyone knows
it it actually happened he will probably
end up in jail at some point if there's
any justice here although you know even
when the Republicans have power down a
lot happens as I brought up with several
Republicans in DC last week but I do
want to play it again because after the
farting incident after fart gate on
MSNBC Chris Matthews claimed that he it
wasn't a fart but that he had moved his
coffee cup but I think if you watch it
carefully you can see swallow adjusting
just so to release the fart in a way
that wasn't going to be picked up the
mic I'll ask then always work out that
way the evidence is uncontradicted that
the president used taxpayer dollars to
ask the ukrainians to help them cheat
them an election and the complaint that
I've heard from actually it was more
than I thought he almost like blew
himself out of the chair anyway that's a
little sidebar but there are other
things happening here it's not just that
the people who've run the political
institutions like Schiff these sham
impeachments and oh he mentions January
6 and it's like nothing's coming from
January 6 guys and nothing's coming from
the Mar-A-Lago raid the FBI basically
admitted it it's just all so ridiculous
they have distracted and Confused
everyone for so long but it's not just
our political institutions
that maybe you're being exposed a little
bit at the moment it's our entertainment
institutions this one is super super
interesting we've got a thread from
Chris Ruffo a breaking Disney has fired
CEO Bob chapek who pushed critical race
Theory and gender ideology in the
company's programming and employee
training huge rebuke of woke leadership
after chapik's disastrous fight with
Governor Ron DeSantis Disney plus
domestic subscriber growth collapsed
public approval dropped and the stock
price plummeted other causes contributed
economy streaming saturation but timing
suggests they paid a price for the
DeSantis fight will be interesting to
see if Iger this is former Disney CEO
Bob Iger who's now taking over who is
also left-wing dials back the politics I
will be reaching out to my sources
within the company in the coming weeks
to see how the internal culture shifts
so this one is super interesting
remember when all that don't say gay
stuff was happening and as you guys know
it had nothing to do with gay or
anything else it was about parents
having some transparency regarding what
their children were learning and who
they were learning it from do you
remember when all those Disney videos
leaked and they were saying all these
employees were saying they were
Institute they were pushing this woke
ideology and the gender stuff into the
movies and everything else well then
Disney starts collapsing everyone
everyone in the mainstream media
DeSantis is bullying Disney because what
did DeSantis do hey we're going to take
away your tax benefits you are treated
specially
right here in Florida your headquarters
Disney obviously in Orlando you guys
have all of these benefits and if you
are going to infect our young people
with these bad ideas we are going to
take these benefits wait he didn't
punish the company by taking away
something that was equal he took away
their special benefits and everyone said
DeSantis is going to pay for it and
suddenly all the lefties who are
supposed to hate corporate power
suddenly then they were all about
corporate power and you know the the
unions and everything else they'll
destroyed to Santa's well
clearly didn't work out that way to say
this one by 20 points here uh just two
weeks ago and uh and I think that's just
the beginning for him uh but it's
interesting because it's one of those
things this don't say gay thing it was
an absolute disaster parents finally are
getting involved and they are pushing
back and when politicians put push back
effectively they win big Steve krakauer
who is Megan Kelly's executive producer
had a really interesting Twitter Thread
about conspiracy theories and I wanted
to put up some of this we've we've
covered most of this stuff but I think
you'll find this interesting he wrote
yesterday's conspiracy theories are
today's Legacy Media news reports a
threat on some interesting stories that
have emerged in just the past nine days
since the midterm elections have been
held surely no relation of course on the
timing I think that was sarcasm and BC
Bay Area reporter big dad Siobhan
reported on the Pelosi attack based on
Source Who Saw body cam footage it was
almost identical to what Miguel almager
said 11 on 11 4 that got him suspended
D.A says Pelosi will need to explain why
he did what he did now just real quick
on that one uh just come back to me for
one second
um on that one that's regarding how it
seemed like on the night of the attack
and it was reported in mainstream media
that Paul Pelosi Nancy's husband
actually opened the door and let the guy
in the glass was broken on the outside
of the house not on the inside of the
house but suddenly we don't talk about
that anymore okay he just continues to
go on here so I'll go a little faster
two Washington Post reports that after
uh that after all that secret docs drama
Trump raid produced basically nothing of
Interest this is the Mar-A-Lago raid do
not point to any nefarious effort by
Trump to leverage sell or use government
secrets more just about ego and keeping
mementos three
there's also the s s b f f t x implosion
who now says F regulators and ESG has
been perverted beyond recognition and
describes the dumb game we woke
westerners play where we say all the
right things conveniently post midterms
of course so this was we're going to get
more into this in just a little bit it
was in essence a giant money laundering
scheme to funnel money to the Democrats
and then of course it gets exposed
basically the day after the election
much like uh basically the day after the
election when the judge decided to
announce that Biden uh just giving
blanket amnesty for all of these college
loans that's not going to work either so
you get all the you get all the money
from FTX you get all the votes of young
people who think their debt's going to
be canceled oh and then the day after
the election not going to work
um let's keep going here we have a few
more or we're going right to oh so there
were a couple more that he put in there
uh but let's let's jump to the FDX thing
actually uh so if you're not following
this FTX story it's it's really really
crazy I want to give you sort of a blue
sky version of it so here's a simple
explanation from the daily wire Sam
bankman freed the now bankrupt founder
of the cryptocurrency exchange FTX
giving gave a staggering sum of money to
Democrats and far left causes this
midterm election cycle before his
multi-billion Dollar Empire imploded
this week FTX which is headquartered in
the Bahamas was launched in 2019 it had
accrued more than one million users by
2022. users suddenly demanded 6 billion
in withdrawals after an article
published by coindesk revealed last week
that the two arms of bankman Freed's
cryptocurrency Empire FTX and Alameda
research had significant overlap on
their balance sheets in the form of
cryptocurrency ftt which f t x invented
I'll explain this a little bit more in
just a moment the disheveled 30-year
year old went from boasting a 15.6
billion dollar net worth to having no
material wealth over the span of
approximately two days federal and state
officials are now investigating whether
bankman freed broke laws with his
actions at the company uh hint yes
bankman freed was the second largest
donor for the Democrats this last
election cycle only behind Mega donor
George Soros giving him at least 38
million to leftist causes giving at
least 38 million to left his causes Pacs
and candidates Fox News reported just a
bit more here Politico reported that
bankman freed was a top resource to whom
Democrats went when lawmakers began
looking at ways to regulate
cryptocurrencies because of his
willingness to write multi-million
dollar checks to boost Democrats okay
now what this all means is that this guy
who was a complete scam artist he
created a centralized cryptocurrency
exchange so any of you that know
anything about crypto the whole idea of
crypto is that it's completely
decentralized right it's a way for you
person watching this and me to exchange
value Bitcoin whatever the
cryptocurrency might be uh without
having anyone else involved so suddenly
all of these centralized exchanges
started appearing right FTX coinbase and
it was very odd why would you put your
decentralized thing of value in a
centralized space seems like a really
bad idea I have some crypto I have not
put it in a centralized space I keep it
on a ledger it is my own I keep it on a
physical actual drive and then I can
exchange it with someone else as I see
fit that's why it's such a threat to the
system it is decentralized payments
decentralized commerce between people so
he creates this completely fraud
Vigilant centralized exchange gets all
of these celebrities and hugely powerful
people to donate it under the guise of
altruistic donations and they're going
to save the world with all this it
always seemed like nonsense I remember
hearing about it like six months ago and
thinking it seemed like pure nonsense
like what's the actual business then he
takes all of this money
and he starts funneling it to Democrats
he was the democrat's second biggest
donor after guess who you're not going
to believe it guys can you can you
figure this one out
yeah George Soros can you believe it can
you believe it and then he got connected
to everyone here's a picture of bankman
freed get some pants nobody wants to see
those pasty white legs this is why
Connor this is why you don't wear shorts
right you never wear shorts It's 107
degrees you don't believe in shorts
it's because only in the pool it's
because of this no like get put on an
outfit man look at this ratty little
asexual weirdo but there he is of course
with former British Prime Minister Tony
Blair and former uh U.S President Bill
Clinton of course that's back in April
of 2022 uh and then Dave Portner you
guys know Dave Portner from Barstool
Sports who knows a bit about these
exchanges and a bit about the market and
what's going on uh he was at Tucker
Carlson I was actually downstairs from
them right there I was having a burger
over at the Hard Rock uh Diner uh he was
on Tucker Carlson at the Hard Rock Hotel
Hollywood just a couple days ago
explaining like hey is anyone gonna pay
for any of this Billy get to the bottom
of what happened no no I mean
I don't know that will truly know what
happened because there's a lot of big
players have probably lost a lot of
money I mean the bankruptcy today what
they release is crazy what they're
spending money on but who knows I never
think we'll know anything I don't want
to be some conspiracy when there's big
money involved I never think I'm getting
a straight shake like I mean honestly
how can Gensler sit down with a guy who
is living in a penthouse in the Bahamas
with 15 people who are all having sex
with each other spending money on
everything and he's like yeah we're
going to write the legislation with you
I mean honestly
how is that possible I can't tie my shoe
this guy's doing that and getting away
with like come on to the White House
let's sit down and you know make some
legislation it's insane yeah so there's
a lot of weird stuff it was like they
were having orgies and all this weird
stuff and this idea that bankman freed
was helping Democrats write legislation
related to crypto he was doing something
that was against the very nature of
crypto if you talk to anyone that knows
anything about Bitcoin or
cryptocurrencies again this idea of the
centralized uh exchange is nuts you
would want it all to be decentralized
but they have a centralized guy so he's
into control writing the laws about
cryptocurrency which is completely
counter to the very ethos of
cryptocurrency in the first place but
this thing this FTX thing it's
everywhere it's affecting and
infiltrating I would say even the world
governments that seem to be coordinating
in some sort of Call Me Crazy conspiracy
theorist I'll be proven right in two
years some sort of uh globalist agenda
we've got some info here from the New
York Post the shocking implosion of the
FTX crypto exchange has become an
embarrassment for a who's who among
Global elites with some issuing Maya
culpas and other apparently scrambling
to hide their ties to its disgraced 30
year old founder Sam bankman freed web
archive sites show that the world
economic Forum shocker whose glitzy
shindig in Davos Switzerland is a must
attend for billionaires
and world leaders each year had
previously listed FTX as one of its
Partners touting the bahamas-based firm
as a cryptocurrency exchange built by
Traders for Traders bankman freed also
was a speaker at Davos last May along
luminaries such as Google financial
Chief Ruth poret and Bill winter CEO of
the london-based financials Giants
Standard Chartered nevertheless World
economic Forum has since scrubbed any
mention of FTX from its website in the
days after the crypto exchange filed for
bankruptcy do you think this is all
weird do you guys think the timing of
this thing is weird there was this giant
Ponzi scheme money laundering machine
that made it all the way to the election
being the second largest Democrat
donoring structure
donation structure and then it implodes
the day after the election and then the
world economic Forum which we know
basically puts world leaders in
positions of power in different Western
governments then they scrub ftx's
relationship off their website within
three four days do you think this is
weird here's Klaus Schwab who's a very
very evil man in charge of the world
economic forum who has had much to do
with destroying so much of freedom and
Western democracy and he tells us he
tells us what he's trying to do and for
some reason mainstream media just won't
cover it I can't figure out why
mainstream Wikipedia would cover it
of course if you look at all the
challenges we can speak about the
multi-crisis
an economic political social and
ecological and institutional crisis
but actually
what we have to confront
is a deep systemic and structural
restructuring of our world
and this will take some time
as the world would look differently
after
we have cons sources transition process
who died and made this douchebag God
do you get what these people are doing
there is a group of billionaires and
Elites who have meetings and launder
money to decide how we will restructure
the world
that is in direct violation of what the
very
the very idea of an independent nation
is an independent nation why did our
Founders leave the king why did we leave
the British Empire so we could have
power over our own lives set laws for
ourselves but this guy thinks if he
could just get enough global leaders and
enough money involved and if they can
buy off enough people and if they can
push things like covet and vaccines and
mandates and all of this stuff that they
can break you and that you will just be
well owning nothing and eating bugs and
loving it and guess what they're not
stopping they really are not stopping
it's it's a little depressing I suppose
but they are not stopping and I promise
you they won't win they just won't win
it's not how it's not how history Works
uh at the G20 they are now supporting
which of course is connected to the
world economic forum and all these
things they are now supporting unanimous
vaccine passports you they're sorry
they're unanimously supporting vaccine
passports and leaders of the G20 are
unanimously supporting a global vaccine
passport system G20 of course a group of
20 major economies including the US the
EU and China
the 20 members agreed to it after
finishing their Summit in Indonesia
here's Indonesia's minister of Health
let's have a digital health certificate
acknowledged by who
if you have been vaccinated or tested
properly then you can move around
so for the next pandemic instead of
stopping the movement of the people 100
which clocked the economy globally you
know you can still provide some movement
of the people
so give people Freedom by taking away
their freedom got it
man
like does it make you a conspiracy
theorist to think that covet was
basically planned whether it was the lab
leak or however this all happened that
it was going to lead to this I mean two
and a half years ago people talking
about how this was all going to lead to
digital passports and all of these
things I mean what what I just want to
be very clear to you G20 people a new
world economic foreign people and you
Klaus Schwab I'm never getting the
vaccine and if that means that I can't
leave the free state of Florida then you
know what so be it I'll be here with the
iguanas and I'll be here with the frogs
and the lizards and I guess I'll be here
with you guys and that's it and then
maybe I'll just be able to go to your
house and you guys all live in the same
building but that they'll just be a very
short trip and I'll visit each one of
you these God these people these freaks
are evil and so that guy who was just
speaking right there uh he's talking
about that you know you will get tested
and you will be mandated and you'll have
this digital passport but that state
that sounds crazy that sounds like a
Philip K dick Total Recall minor already
report sort of thing that can't be
happening right now I mean that can't be
possible that people would have to have
QR codes on their phones that are
genetically connected to them just so
that they could get on trains that
couldn't be happening in on planet Earth
right now China
yeah that's China That's China right now
so it's happening in front of our eyes
and the question is how many politicians
has China bought that are sitting in our
Halls of power right now well one of the
other interesting things related to
covid it's not just that they wanted a
digital ID and maybe they can just shut
down your bank accounts if you say
something mean about the elderly man
pretending to be president or whatever
it might be but it is coming out that
myocarditis uh is a problem and a lot of
people warned of it that there were
heart problems related to these vaccines
here's NBC News a little late but okay
myocarditis after coveted vaccination
Pfizer and moderna are tracking adverse
health effects if any that may appear in
the Years following a diagnosis of
vaccine Associated heart problems you
guys may remember that our uh Surgeon
General here in Florida Joseph latipo a
few weeks ago posted a research paper
about
myocarditis and young men and how it's
up something like if you don't have to
quote me exactly I think it was
something like 800 percent Twitter
censored him and took it down then they
said it was a mistake all the usual
stuff uh and what's going on in Oregon
you can see I'm painting I'm pulling all
these things together what's going on in
Oregon now we're going to drop the
Oregon one okay we're going to drop the
Oregon one we're doing things on the fly
all right what's going on in Canada well
we here's a slightly I want to put it
out there we've slightly altered this
video
um but here's Justin Trudeau and a
little something about Freedom or lack
thereof everyone's tired of covet
but these protests
these protests are not the way to get
through it
we just had to throw that one and I saw
it it's just like yes Justin Trudeau who
has many times been in blackface
constantly telling everyone else they're
racist that was at the height of the
protests when there were truckers who
simply wanted to go back to work not be
forced to be injected with things want
to be able to get on planes without
government permission and all of that
stuff it's just it's just not stopping
it's just not stopping and that is why
guys I'll get to this more towards the
end but that is why local control over
your life and your family and your city
and state is so important because it is
bottom up that will destroy these giant
top-down monsters that are coming for
all of us but it's not just Tech and
media and entertainment and finance and
government the universities have
completely been taken over and maybe we
should have all known about this 30
years ago but now it has become very
obvious here's some info from The Blaze
University of Notre Dame mandates
bivalent covid-19 jab to enroll for
23-24 academic year including students
studying or performing research remotely
and or virtually do you guys see how
insane this is we are still talking
about vaccine mandates years later and
do you think that maybe is connected to
that Klaus Schwab Guy saying we are
going to have to restructure the World
Imagine a university saying yes you
cannot come here if you don't get this
vaccine and that booster oh and it
doesn't even matter if you're not even
on campus it has nothing to do with
covid guys it's about Mass control but
the universities have been collapsing
for a long long time there are literally
universities today that have segregated
housing and it is not because of those
right Wingers and those racist white
supremacists and those scary Republicans
it's because of the leftists and the
progressives who some somehow think that
modern racism is the answer to Historic
racism Dennis Prager was talking about
it a couple days ago but it said for
example controversial conservative
coming to University Dennis Prager
controversial conservative coming to the
University of Wisconsin-Madison
so I have a question that I'd like that
that writer if if he or she is here
to
dwell upon
have you ever written a an article about
a controversial liberal
are there controversial liberals
or are there only controversial
conservatives or here's another one are
there any conservatives who come here
who aren't controversial
or is it definitional to being
conservative and it is
that's the point
at the American University today it is
definitional that if you are not on the
left you are controversial
that is a perfect admission on their
part that there is a norm that is
acceptable and that is left-wing and
outside of it you are controversial you
do realize what I've said that's
controversial I don't believe in Black
dormitories that is today a
controversial statement when I was your
age that was the essence of liberalism
pro-racial integration
anti-racial segregation do you think
it's a good thing to have black
graduation exercises at Harvard
do you think it's good to have black
dormitories at almost all college
campuses if you do you're on the left if
you don't you're a liberal or a
conservative
a part where he talks about how liberals
used to fight against these things the
things that progressives are ushering in
now the woke racism the gender stuff it
was the Liberals of the 60s Berkeley the
home of free speech women burning their
bras the liberals who were locked arm in
arm with Martin Luther King Jr who
wanted equality not equity and they've
become the most hysterical
authoritarians but all right guys you
got it you get what's going on here
we're fighting we're exposing okay fine
but it's not just enough to criticize
the culture right we can criticize the
culture all we want you have to create
the culture and I really believe that is
happening right now and there will be
losses along the way there will be
disappointments at The Ballot Box and a
whole bunch more but I think if you look
at Elon and Twitter if you look at what
Rumble and locals are doing if you look
at the Florida blueprint perhaps more
than anything else the Florida blueprint
of the home of Freedom led by good
competent people that because decent
people voted them in that is the way
that we can shift the culture because
the culture shifted here the culture
shifted here and everyone that's in
Florida except for a hysterical minority
is is pretty happy it's pro-freedom here
it's pro-family here it's pro-decency
here it's pro-individual here uh and
here's Governor Ron DeSantis talking
about the world economic forum and guess
what they ain't going to make their way
into this state I want to have the
values not of Davos imposed on us but of
places like Destin and Dunedin where I
grew up things like the world economic
Forum those policies are Dead on Arrival
in the State of Florida all right so it
ain't going to be easy but he's going to
fight it and you can sometimes it's
easier to fight from a state perhaps
than from a giant Nation right there's a
Machinery in a state that's that's
humming along and doing well and being
strengthened and now he's feeling really
great after this 20-point win and he can
do a whole bunch more but they're
working on some ESG stuff to keep that
out of Florida and a whole bunch more so
what is the Florida blueprint well
listen to Ron DeSantis
[Applause]
I'm praying for success and I think some
of the things that we do that work are
uh we're all about exercising leadership
and delivering results for the people
that we represent I did not take any
polls when I became Governor all the way
through this entire term the job of a
leader is not to stick your finger in
the wind and try to contort yourself to
wherever a public opinion may be
trending on one given moment no the job
of a leader is to set out a vision to
execute that Vision to show people that
it's the right vision and to deliver
concrete results and when you do that
the people respond and boy on November
8th did they ever respond in the state
of Florida
all right so that was Ron DeSantis this
past weekend but I don't only want to
focus on Florida it is the blueprint I
hope that those of you that are watching
if you're in a blue State I hope you're
thinking about moving and I haven't
thrown any money here in a while but
we've got the jar of money that we'll
give to somebody at the end of the year
but it isn't just Florida where the
right ideas are spreading you may
remember uh may remember about two
months ago when Italy had an election
and now they have uh new prime minister
Georgia Maloney and of course she gets
in and she's on the right so everyone
says she's a fascist this is going to
bring us back to World War II she's evil
blah blah blah but if you just listen to
her speeches which they will not show
you on CNN and they're not going to type
out transcripts of in the Washington
Post or the New York Times what she is
talking about is sovereignty Italian
sovereignty she's talking about secure
borders she's talking about caring about
her citizens before this globalist
agenda and she gave a another I mean
she's really I think the star in World
politics ticks right now she gave a
absolutely spectacular speech about
globalism and here she's hitting France
in particular when it comes to these
these globalist ideas and the exploitive
hypocrisy of the whole freaking thing
is
question
questions
[Applause]
that accent I just love the accent and
the fire at the end her point is in this
case she's talking directly to France
but I think you can export this idea or
you can you can compare this idea to
what's going on with the globalist you
guys create all of these problems all
over the world why do 14 Nations use uh
French money right and then you abuse
the people there you know funny when
I've done my uh funny it's I guess
depressing to some level when I've done
my Off the Grid August a couple times we
went to Bora Bora it's in French
Polynesia meaning that the French are
basically occupying these Polynesian
Islands and you know what happens all of
the natives all of the Polynesians that
live on these islands all they they're
bet the best job that you can get is to
work at one of these Resorts now usually
the top staff at the resorts they're all
French uh meaning they're native French
people but you can be a cleaning lady at
a resort you can be a bartender at a
resort or a waitress at a resort and
those are the best jobs you can get in
French Polynesia but we don't talk about
occupation or anything else anyway her
point is we in her context she's talking
about the Italians is I want to protect
our borders we don't need to allow all
of these people in because we feel
guilty about the good civilization we've
built how about we point the finger at
the people who are exploiting the
African nations in this case she's
talking about the French now let's do a
full Circle back to Twitter Free Speech
this was really spectacular there was
the prageru gala was in Los Angeles over
the last couple days I I wanted to go it
was just it's been a lot of travel I do
have two new kids here uh needed to
wanted to be around them a little bit
so it didn't happen but Jordan Peterson
sat down with Dennis Prager and they
talked about the real fight that is
happening right now if you don't have
the idea of the sovereignty of the
individual because there's no individual
there's no free speech
all you are is an avatar of your group
interests and if I'm not in your group
it's not in my interest to let you speak
there's nothing that we have to say to
one another there's nothing but Power
it's a hobbesian nightmare of group
against group
and that's the postmodern Doctrine
and so it's to call it appalling is to
barely scrape the surface it's it's an
assault it is it is truly an assault on
the most fundamental principles by which
the West is governed it's not
surface level philosophy
it goes all the way to the bottom
I mean this is partly why I've been
concentrated on religious themes in my
lectures let's say
because the argument goes all the way
down to First principles
is there
is the in is the idea of the sovereignty
of the individual
correct
the Western answer is it's the great
discovery of the West the Western answer
is that's the most fundamental truth
that is exactly what's under assault at
the universities the reason that the
collectivist types hate me
is because I've got their number
the sovereignty of the individual your
ability to think and act and make
decisions for yourself and your family
and your community that's bottom up
that's the way it's supposed to be but
the collectivists the people who believe
in group identity The Plea the people
who believe in these giant organizations
like the world economic forum and the
CDC and big government all these things
they think if they can just take away
your individual Choice make you a little
Cog in a machine that they will own you
and they might be right and that's what
we have to fight and that's what we must
continue to fight and that is why they
hate Jordan Peterson and that's why it
is great that thanks to Elon Musk that
he is now back on Twitter and that's why
it's also great that Donald Trump at
least he's not back on his his account
has been restored he hasn't tweeted yet
and he may never tweet by the way you
know Donald Trump has truth social he is
tied up financially there uh with the
you know with the parent company of of
Truth and probably has all sorts of
limitations so there's all sorts of
things happening but the opportunity for
more speech the opportunity for more
thoughtful interesting people to get
their voices out there and guess what
even some bad people to get their voices
out there and then let's let these
things fight out in the open
that's good
that is good it's me Monday over at the
Reuben of poor locals Community here's
what I put up this morning I thought
this was just absolutely perfect Donald
Trump looking at his reinstated Twitter
account is he going to get on yes or no
obviously that's Family Guy right there
let me get to a couple comments from the
locals community and then we got a funny
uh call close for you Mark says
swalwell's mouth couldn't handle the
crap spewing so his ass had to come bail
him out yes I think you are quite right
on that one Ohana says Twitter isn't an
airport you don't have to announce your
departure yes that's that's funny so
there's all these people on Twitter that
you know these lefties that are I'm
leaving today and then they come back
tomorrow I mean it's it's basically what
CBS is doing it's like go build some
things you know if I did one thing right
over these couple years I think I did a
few things right but if I did one it's
that we built locals because I always
felt no matter who owns this and I still
feel it even with Elon even though I
like the guy I hope to meet him maybe we
can do some business together but like
you gotta own own your stuff that was
the whole purpose of why we started
locals that was why we merged with
Rumble and those are the right you know
it's like if any of the the progressives
or lefties had created their own thing
right now they'd have a place to go to
but they don't have a place to go to so
they can [ __ ] and moan all they want
but you're right they're they're not
leaving the airport uh Corgi mom says
last night around the dinner table my
mom said a I'm a trump person and I
voted for him but I hope he doesn't get
the nomination he's done look
I'm hearing a lot of that I'm hearing a
lot of that my travels in the last week
DC and then the the fox Awards meeting a
lot of people and a lot of people are
feeling like the attacks on DeSantis
were overboard they're just tired of the
thing
um of the of all of the stuff all of the
baggage that it comes with I think
there's good arguments on both sides he
still is the center of the universe for
good or worse for good or bad right he
really is there the machine hates him
the most maybe he has the most juice to
fight the machine I think that's a
that's a good argument he's done it
before maybe he can do it again on the
counter side can he bring in any new
voters has he already hit his ceiling
is he can he get enough good people to
work with him you know a lot of good
people are are not in the mood to work
with him anymore that's just reality so
again I will if he's the nominee I'm
voting for him if this ad is the nominee
I'm voting for him who knows if the
Santa's even wants to run but there's
but yes there's there is a shift
happening and I wonder to some degree
because Trump has not been on Twitter
for so long if he maybe can't read the
tea leaves actually as well as he used
to all that being said I will gladly sit
down with him I would sit down with him
and DeSantis we'll work on it and I will
ask them both the exact same questions
and give them the exact amount of
allotted time just to show an
impartiality related to all of that and
and you know let's see what happens uh
guys in light of everything that's going
on on Twitter and big Tech and
everything else and when you talk about
uh some dangerous ideas you could get
booted from anything so please if you
have not joined us already you can
create an absolutely free account at
reubenreport.locals.com you can throw in
a couple bucks if you want to interact a
little bit more but it's a great way in
case I get booted from Big Tech to stay
in touch and of course you can subscribe
at Reuben report uh uh sorry at
rumble.com reubenreport my interviews
with Rand Paul Jim Jordan and Scott
Walker from last week are up uh we have
a couple more coming out this week and
we leave you with a cold close the me
makers are excited because Donald J
Trump is back in action
[Music]
s
[Music]
big
dick I'll create a monster cause nobody
wants to see I know more than they want
Trump shot liver well if you want Trump
this is
[Music]
[Music]
like your husband's heart problems
[Music]